we shall stay in the great state of
Arizona where Carrie lake is running for
governor against Katie Hobbs here's
Katie Hobbs talking about her position
on Democrat I should say Katie Hobbs
discussing her position on abortion the
Hobbes administration's weak limit be
for abortion access if it's not 15 weeks
what is it
look abortion is a very personal
decision that belongs between a woman
and her doctor the government and
politicians don't belong in that
decision we need to let doctors perform
the care that they are trained and take
an oath to to perform so if an Arizona
voter were to conclude from your
previous answer that you do not favor
any specific weak limit on abortion
would they be correct
I support leaving the decision between a
woman and her doctor and leaving
politicians entirely out of it
doesn't she come off as an SNL character
like they like dressed her up and put on
fake glasses and I'm pretty sure doctors
taken oath not to do any harm I think
that has something to do with the
hypocratical if you're supposed to help
everybody we can discuss whether
abortion is okay fine you got it but all
right so who is the moderate does that
seem like a moderate position that a
woman should just be able to get
abortion at any point again I say this
is someone that believes you would want
a certain window to allow for abortion
but is that the moderate position or the
radical position and and think about it
this way 20 years ago not even 20 years
ago 12 years ago and perhaps even less
six years ago if a Democrat had said I
believe I believe in No Limits to
abortion they would have been the
outlier in the party but now they are
all repeating the exact same stuff show
me a Democrat who isn't repeating the
exact same nonsense so okay that's her
position you can decide whether it's
radical or moderate for yourself here is
Republican Carrie Lake explaining her
position on abortion I am I'm a woman
I'm a mother I'm all for Women's Health
Care I come from a large family Seven
Sisters I have of course I want Women's
Health Care this has moved Beyond health
care we're not giving women choices I'm
forgiving women true choices and when
they walk into an abortion Center
they're only given one choice they're
not told that you have the choice to
keep your baby and we can help and
here's how or we can help you find a
loving family who will adopt your baby I
want to give women true choices I will
uphold the Law whatever that law is and
I want to see to it that we save more
lives right now the Democrats have
started pushing so far from that rare
but safe to anything goes up to nine
months of pregnancy after birth Katie
Hobbs my opponent actually is voted for
and you look at a voting record allowing
a baby who survives an abortion they
that the hospital would refuse Medical
Care and allow the baby to die on a cold
metal tray did you catch that last part
this is what they call post-birth
abortions where the the woman and her
doctor could decide ah you know sure the
baby's out of you but there's this
little window to still in essence I
think we usually call that murder that
would be known as murder and again as
someone that just spent a couple days uh
you know in the hospital uh with these
with these preemies and and the babies
all in there and watching that it's just
it's it's just absolutely mind-blowing
uh she also had an interesting line
there
um which was I will uphold the Law
whatever the law is because of course
she's running for governor so she's not
setting the law the law is set by the
legislature but she's saying I will
honor the Law whatever the law is she
has her own again personal belief
um I'm trying to find out if she has any
weak exception on that but she's saying
I want choice in that if a woman is
pregnant instead of automatically
pushing her towards the abortion which
of course we know the Democrats want to
do instead of doing that what she would
like to do is say hey can we help you
perhaps put this baby up for adoption or
we can maybe we can give you you some
resources so you will feel you don't
have to get an abortion and okay I'm
being given some information right now
this is nice to hear uh Carey Lake's
position on this is 15 weeks 15 weeks
that seems to be the magic number that's
according to Rolling Stone and rolling
stone is no friend of the Republicans
and by the way 15 weeks is the current
law in Arizona so who is more radical
the person who wants to keep it at three
and a half months in essence which is
the current law or or the person who
wants to expand it into eight months
I think you got it so Will these two
debate because it seems like they have a
real difference of opinion it might be
nice if they got on a stage together and
talked it out uh well Katie Katie Hobbs
was asked about debating Carrie and she
ain't into it one more time before we
let you go because I think it is on the
mind of Arizona voters are you saying
this morning that there is no
circumstance that you can Envision or
would even try to negotiate in which you
and Kerry Lake would appear at a debate
together before the election
at this point in the race with 30 days
to go our schedule in terms of of forums
is pretty much set and and I'm really
happy with where we are in uh the plans
we have to continue talking directly to
the voters of Arizona guys she just
doesn't have time to have a debate with
her opponent it's such nonsense they are
afraid to explain their positions
because their positions have become
radical